el carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
les doy la bienvenida a esta nueva
temporada de carrusel de las artes desde
la ciudad de perpiñán en el suroeste de
francia hoy vamos a recorrer algunas de
las exposiciones del festival de
fotoperiodismo más importantes del mundo
[Música]
perpignan congrega a los mejores
fotoperiodistas del mundo en el marco
del festival visa pour l'image los
conflictos y las crisis en el planeta
monopolizan buena parte de las
exposiciones fotográficas aunque se han
colado otros fenómenos como la aparición
de los empleados nómadas y el
teletrabajo
daremos también un salto al museo de
arte moderno de lille que expone la obra
proteiforme y prolífica del artista
argentino guillermo kuitca quien explora
el vacío y el arte que él llama koubbi
estoy de iu en nuestra crónica musical
fuimos al encuentro de toma mónica
guitarrista excepcional y cantante quien
nos transporta al universo de la
mitología griega con su disco ulises
[Música]
perpignan vuelve a ser la meca de la
fotografía de prensa a través del wisla
por limar el famoso festival de
fotoperiodismo este año la edición
número 33 se compone de 25 exposiciones
abiertas al público de forma gratuita en
diferentes puntos de la ciudad
[Música]
el suntuoso hotel palms de la ciudad de
perpiñán acoge una serie de fotografías
realizadas en la región de tigre en el
norte de etiopía allí se libra un
cruento conflicto desde noviembre de
2020 entre el ejército etíope y los
rebeldes del frente de liberación del
pueblo de tigre vamos a descubrirla
[Música]
tigre etiopía se hunde en el caos se
compone de 36 fotos sobre las
consecuencias devastadoras de la guerra
para la población civil su autor es el
argentino eduardo soteras quien fue uno
de los pocos periodistas autorizados a
entrar en la zona según el gobierno
etíope la ofensiva contra los rebeldes
debía ser rápida y sin riesgo para los
civiles las imágenes de soteras muestran
otra realidad destrucción y masacres
como la perpetrada en marca dra en
noviembre de 2020
lo que yo tenía en mente era primero
documentar la situación
particularmente con el tema de médica
drag ser meto un discurso político
acerca de la hernia que quien fue quien
no dio el tema es una masacre para mí el
discurso principal de cualquier
fotografía de conflicto tiene que ser
miren esto no debería estar ocurriendo
no debería estar ocurriendo hoy en día
en las fotos de eduardo solteras niños
que leen sobre los restos de una escuela
familiares que rezan sobre una fosa
común hambruna el fotógrafo también
captó el sufrimiento de las mujeres
víctimas de violación y agresiones
sexuales
[Música]
en la parte que más me afectó tiene que
ver con las mujeres cuando pudimos
entrar en merkel en marzo de este año y
empezamos a recoger testimonios de
supervivientes de violencia sexual para
mí de las fotos más representativas es
una de las fotos que se ha utilizado en
los pósters del festival pero yo me
recuerdo de la historia de esa mujer y
es trágico y es triste no la estética
cinética es cosmética no entonces espero
no haber caído en la cosmética y haber
sido fiel con lo que creo y con las
personas a las cuales documente
[Música]
en 2021 obispo libar aborda la situación
de los migrantes en tiempos de kobe en
la exposición colectiva doble pena a los
refugiados en la crisis sanitaria el
fotógrafo francés guillaume vide
participó en esta muestra con sus fotos
tomadas en x
[Música]
para los haitianos que han enfrentado
huracanes terremotos violencia y
autoridades en las que no confían la
llegada de la cob it significó además el
cierre del turismo y de las fronteras es
un país que vive gracias a la diáspora a
las personas que trabajan en república
dominicana y a la economía informal que
quedó completamente paralizada muchos
haitianos trataron de huir de la miseria
y los que vivían en república dominicana
perdieron su trabajo y fueron obligados
a retornar a haití lo que ya son
volvieron
por eso hablamos de doble pena porque la
situación social económica y política es
catastrófica y a esto se le suma la
crisis sanitaria que ha impedido que
haití levante cabeza de romper de golpe
la t3 social la tendrá
[Música]
este año el festival visa publimar ya
reservó un espacio a la exploración de
la naturaleza y de la fauna salvaje así
como fenómenos propios de nuestro tiempo
el trabajo o teletrabajo captó la
atención de gijón jones el fotógrafo
francés fue el encuentro de los nuevos
nómadas digitales que se han instalado
en países como indonesia o portugal
buscando un espacio soleado para
trabajar
[Música]
en el coworking alcohol y bing y los
cocoteros es la nueva realidad para
muchos jóvenes occidentales que han
creado nuevas rutinas de trabajo lejos
de sus países de origen una realidad que
yo con jones había descubierto mucho
antes de la pandemia
[Música]
mi intención con esta serie era explorar
cómo los aparatos y la conectividad han
moldeado nuestra forma de trabajar en
bari descubrí gente que mucho antes de
lakovic dejaban el mundo occidental para
instalarse en una isla paradisíaca que
le permitía trabajar y disfrutar de la
vida luego llegó la pandemia y él de
trabajo lo que me permitió darle
seguimiento a esas personas que
regresaban a europa filmus
este nuevo modo de trabajar y de vivir
atrae a muchos jóvenes en ruptura con
las sociedades en crisis
estos jóvenes finalmente son el reflejo
de un malestar social son gente que
nació en sociedades donde el futuro es
incierto con tasas de desempleo altas
que ofrecen pocas cosas para los jóvenes
esa precariedad los empuja a buscar
alternativas a trabajar en un mundo
precario pero con la sensación de que no
están desperdiciando su juventud
[Música]
de perpiñán vamos salir en el norte de
francia el museo de arte moderno de esa
ciudad ha hecho una invitación especial
al argentino guillermo kuitca uno de los
artistas abstractos más prominentes de
américa latina' desenlace es el nombre
de esta muestra donde puede admirarse la
obra prote informe de kuitca
[Música]
sillas camas instalaciones o
composiciones con acentos cubistas en su
obra guillermo kuitca ha explorado
temáticas recurrentes en múltiples
soportes el museo de arte moderno de
lille expone cerca de 200 obras de este
prodigio nacido en buenos aires
considerado artista desde sus 14 años
[Música]
crítica estamos muy felices de mostrar
la obra de guillermo kuitca líder la
exposición no está pensada con una
retrospectiva sino como un panorama con
la obra de kuyt que es proteiforme
guillermo es pintor pero también hacen
instalaciones y dibujos que tengan
vínculos con otras artes como el teatro
la ópera y la danza en su organismo o
incluso el psicoanálisis también
incursionó en el cubismo pero él lo
llama arte cubista y con unas que vemos
al final de la exposición
guillermo kuitca invita en su obra a
explorar territorios desconocidos la
página en blanco la escena vacía la
soledad aunque algunos motivos son casi
una obsesión
las camas y los mapas son dos temáticas
que kuitca ha explorado mucho el artista
asocio esos dos elementos primero en el
89 y luego en el 92 en la documenta de
kassel en alemania allí presentó una
instalación de 20 camas sobre las cuales
están pintados mapas de europa central
se han dicho muchas cosas sobre esta
obra fundamental del arte contemporáneo
kuitca socio aquí el espacio íntimo de
una cama con el espacio abstracto y el
exotismo que representan esos mapas y su
pasado como hijo de inmigrantes judíos
ucranianos
la bailarina piña bausch o el español
pablo picasso inspiraron a kuitca a sí
mismo sombras trágicas y personajes
fantasmagóricos hacen pensar en la
historia convulsa de argentina
[Música]
guillermo no entra en el arte político a
diferencia de otros artistas argentinos
que también vivieron la dictadura
militar aunque en varias series aborde
el tema de los desaparecidos pero su
trabajo es mucho más amplio como para
meterlo en una sola categoría él mismo
se considera un artista argentino pero
siempre ha rechazado las etiquetas o que
otros han querido ponerle
[Música]
ahora ya de nuestra crónica musical y
para ello vamos a parís de la mano de
natalio olivares quien conoció a un
cantante y guitarrista que ha
redescubierto con su música la mitología
griega y la odisea de homero
la melodía de su guitarra nos llevó al
distrito número 2 de parís hasta la
oficina de la agencia musical y feliz la
melodía de toma mónica quien nos recibió
para hablarnos de su proyecto ulises
solís su nuevo disco que nació casi al
mismo tiempo que su hijo que también
llamó iris una historia de su vida la de
una artista
[Música]
el trabajo de un artesano musical el
término artista me resulta pretencioso
es escribir sobre la vida cotidiana y
tejer historias es un poco como la vida
de ulises y por eso escribí el paralelo
con la odisea de homero porque es un
poco lo que vivimos todos los días al
final es
como
[Música]
viajar por su álbum sería una odisea
entonces pues por las dudas lo
escuchamos y la verdad es que podríamos
tener todos un poco de ulises un
antihéroe que viaja por la tierra
maltratada por los hombres en su canción
moli toma mónica asocia las palabras
madres y amarguras
[Música]
y es una referencia a la planta antídoto
de la mitología que impide a ulises
transformarse en un personaje el mundo
se puede ver desde el ángulo ecológico
también para mí la madre naturaleza está
reaccionando en los combate por el
maltrato que recibe lo que le sucede a
la amazonía por ejemplo donde el pulmón
de la tierra se está muriendo y si
agregamos lo que nos pasa con el kobe 19
para mí eso es una respuesta de la
tierra una rebelión
toma mónica comenzó como genio de la
guitarra primero como solista y luego
junto al conocido en ahora vuela con sus
propias alas también como cantante pero
nunca sin su guitarra
[Música]
la guitarra está presente en todas sus
formas en mi disco en la canción moli
hice un solo de guitarra española que me
gusta mucho pero también hay un estilo
más rock en otras canciones y también
toco guitarra al estilo árabe es una
mezcla de todos mis orígenes de la
cuenca mediterránea al fin y al cabo
este álbum es un poco mi casa
[Música]
gracias natal olivares y con la música
de toma monica vamos a despedir este
programa especial que les presentamos
desde la ciudad de piñón ya saben que
pueden seguirnos en la web y redes
sociales de rf y france24 en español
gracias por su sintonía y hasta la
próxima aguaje
[Música]
mi familia
los actos son somos amor que te gusta
muchísimo
la misión este es el mundo